ora pulsos audição mais um vídeo e hoje
vou ensinar o que fazer com marmo
sampaio tinha de picolé pronto em
londres é bastante fácil encontrar à
venda nas papelarias em portugal que eu
ganhei um beijo e não faço ideia mas é
provável também haja venda de uma arma
pessoal então vocês vão ter que usar
óculos potencial enorme para contra
ninguém porque é isto tempo força
vejam só que até volta por trás do
roteiro está a água com mais definição
ea xingou muito bonita não sei que vocês
acham que vocês gostaram da china os
comentários que eu gosto sempre saber
essas coisas
ontem os manetes pararam por um podendo
então quando agarrou um punhal
pressionarem com força na web para quem
esta imagem vou deixar limpo na
descrição vocês carregam vão ser
direcionados para a página do facebook e
lá vocês vão ter a imagem é provável que
não seja a medida então o que vocês vão
fazer vão contar o odin e desenhar em
casa uma vez que o papel de pronto o
quadriculado é universal
estou usar aqui os políticos da segunda
linha pronto segundo jânio para fazer a
parte do cano
convém sempre tirar o chefe da escola
vai ficar tudo limpinho lá dentro depois
não não dá problema depois para
conseguir sair
as bolas nossas bolas vamos dizer assim
é muita atenção no encaixe pessoal vejam
bem como ficou aqui é maior lá tem ficar
um quadrado e não um retângulo publicar
um retângulo é provável que os lápis não
tenha espaço para estar lá dentro a quem
dão muita atenção e nesta parte final
foi um pouco e cola porque você que já
não vão conseguir tirar o chefe lado
dentro aqui agora usar de um elástico e
o conselho que você usa o elástico do
escritor um escritório no auditório
parte logo um elástico de costureira
porque é bastante resistente e tem muito
mais força aqui
quanta gente vai colar então vai ser
muito complicado depois substituído
agora esta parte estou agora vou colar o
imposto em 1962 políticos
essa distância varia bastante varia
pronto tendo voz elástico voz hilário
furlan e esticar bastante
você escolhe disputa em desempenho mais
para trás agora se eu não ficar tanto no
teclado time mais para frente vocês
o verão aqui e já vamos estar nessa
parte da equipa à frente exatamente como
vai pressionar contra a mesa para
alinhar os dois já caí vejo o elat tem
que passar os dois políticos
agora está parado é para não forçar o
político instalado desenhado mas é
provável que o tamanho varia no crime
porque conseguiu consoante o tamanho de
nossos políticos também candidato cola e
essa chance lá no meio vai variar então
você se ajustam 750 também o lápis vão
cortar do tamanho do plano põe lá e vem
mais ou menos eu estou aqui pronto um
x-ato mas se você estiver pronto não
tiverem podem usar uma serra e até
melhor aquelas pequenas como tal agora
fazia parte do grupo tido muita atenção
vai jogo que vou deixar sem saúde um
dedo cortar-lhe a linha paralela ser
paralelo com a extremidade do lápis e
preocupo se desgastar desta maneira com
mais pormenor
agora esta para conquistar a sonhada lá
vocês vão ter que fazer como eu estou
fazendo aqui é só o funcionário falou
tenho e depois cortar é que neste
coletivo que o episódio vai vai segurar
aqui você já ouvir daqui para frente é
só colar
estou aqui a parte do lápis para
empurrar que o nosso estão da amarok vai
jolie é que parte do corte fica virado
para o pelo time que nós aqui vamos
declarar que saiu vocês não saibam
identificar prender nela a imagem olim é
muito importante esta para sempre ficar
sozinho e depois não funciona porque a
propósito agora pra vocês verem qual é
parte de baixo e para cima
a partir daí pelo técnico lado é parte
fica por baixo e parte vai ficar pronto
eo punho ok eu como é que eu tô indo a
uma pequena distância ali para conseguir
pular o claro este grande aqui estando
varia um crime você esposa justo aqui
composição do vosso gosto
agora por outro lado não tem cola e
ponham ficará em direito e estou pronto
segurar o político vai ficar à distância
correta pelos cara aí
depois de ficar é só colar pelo time que
usaram para manter a distância de usar
que cola quente
agora as outras escolas também usarão o
enem depende de algumas são bastante
fraquinho mas não ficou bonito mas ficou
bastante frágil então eu vou dar aqui
mais reforçada é usando pronto mais pelo
time e claro né
veja aqui bastante simples ocultar
extremidades ver o tamanho por cola e
por lá dentro e fazer que somente 1 x
vocês viram no início arma tinha mais
mais positivos nesta para as plantas ou
o vídeo não ficar muito longo
é bastante simples você só medem cortam
e depois é só colar para forçar a
estrutura e também prontos podem fazer o
vosso próprio feita silva símbolo foi
laís e dá pra variar muito nesta partida
e ser parte mais difícil e que estarmos
só e privada é agora óculos de proteção
e que mais uns testes vizinhos
bom pessoal chegamos aqui e espero que o
estado que vocês gostaram mesmo deixe
vascaína voz favorito e se inscreva no
canal que isto ajuda bastante a
divulgação ea poluição dos meus projetos
muito obrigado e até à próxima champions
e é